okay so you see this drop-off right here
to go from here dow jones to all the way
down here in one day that's not a good
thing and that's what happened to the
market yesterday after
the media got a hold of uh biden's
proposal
on his tax plan and the market went nuts
they went crazy
uh dow dropped a percent in a day uh
even bitcoin dropped uh you know from 55
dow
all the way down to uh 49 thou and you
know
even bitcoin just a few days ago was at
65 000
high sixty two thousand dollars and
outside the down of forty nine thousand
dollars but the market's been reacting
what happened with this biden
tax plan you know new york times writing
articles about it bidens
this is bloomberg biden eyeing tax rate
as high as 43.4 percent
in a next economic package market watch
talking about how get ready 478 billion
dollars selling ahead
of the capital gains tax hike that's
going to happen this year
bitcoin drops below 50 000 and then
there's another story here by reuters
which uh
fantastic story biden to float historic
tax increase
on investment gains on the rich and
we're gonna get a little bit into it
and and here's a reality about taxes i'm
gonna show you a video by the time we're
done with
is the following there are three camps
that are gonna be
going through the tax hikes okay number
one is those who directly know
that they're gonna be affected by this
right and we'll talk about those guys
those who indirectly are aware that
they're going to be affected by this
and then there's a third camp you know
who it is those who are not aware
that they're indirectly going to be
affected by this i'll address
all those three camps here in a minute
but let's read this article here
on what they talk about with the tax
plan so
president joe biden will roll out a tax
plan on uh raise taxes
on the wealthiest americans including
the largest ever increase in levies on
investment gains to fund about
a trillion dollars in child care
universal pre-kindergarten education and
paid leave
for workers sources familiar to the
proposal set the plan is a part of a
white house push to sweep an overhaul of
ul tax system
to make the rich and big companies pay
more and help foot the
bill for biden's ambitious economic
agenda the proposal calls
for increasing the top marginal income
tax rate from uh to 39.6 from 237 from
and sources said that this week it would
also nearly double
capital gains to 39.6 for people earning
more than a million dollars
that would be the highest tax rate on
investment gains which are mostly paid
by the wealthiest americans
since 1920s the rate has
not exceeded 33.8 in the post
world war ii modern era it's also
corporate tax rates going from 21
to 28 that they're also pitching as well
and to kind of put the numbers here at
the bottom of what it says uh where is
the one
with it gives you the idea about the
states let's see here okay all the way
in the bottom
okay this is good here erica york an
economist at the tax foundation said the
proposal would put u.s capital gains
taxes at the top of the global charts
anywhere around the world
average capital gains taxes in europe is
around 19.3 can you imagine europe is
known for being a socialistic
european union the average is 193
today's usa capital gains
is 23.9 because it's 20 plus the
obamacare
that you put on top of that so we are
higher than socialistic countries in
europe currently
even with the 2039 and the highest rate
is denmark which collects 42 france and
finland charge
34 for residents of some states and
cities that assess their own capital
gains levy
biden's tax plan would push to the total
capital gains rate
to more than 50 percent york said the
rate would rise to 56.7 percent in
california
68.2 in new york city and 57.3
in portland oregon you see these numbers
here 68.2
in new york city that almost doesn't
even look real when you read a number
like that
68.2 so now if you're looking at this
what are you thinking well there's a few
different things to be thinking about
i'm surprised that people are surprised
what do i mean by this
see on the podcast here this is
september 4th
2020. i want to zoom in so you see the
date september 4
2020 it's myself it's adam
it's tom zenner we're talking about
biden's tax plan
that he proposed seven months ago
meaning you're either somebody who voted
and you said he'll never do this they'll
never raise the taxes
you were naive or you voted saying i
hope they raise the taxes and he's
keeping his commitment
or you voted against him because you
feared this was gonna happen
and it's happening but regardless
everybody's in one of three camps
and i read an email in this show that i
got from goldman sachs i want to play it
for you only for the
first few minutes let me put the speed
on 1.5
if you want to slow down you can slow
down on your end but i'm going to listen
to it on 1.5 so we can speed up this
process so let's take a look at
what we're talking about on this podcast
episode
button's tax plan how about we talk
about in snacks so check this out last
week
i'm minding my own business we're at our
annual convention we're preparing for
we've got a lot of stuff going on
i get an email from goldman sachs from
authorizer goldman sachs good people
there we like them a lot they do good
for us
we every time we run them very very
helpful this is not an article written
by
you know someone on huffpost this is not
an article written by a contributor on
force
this is from goldman sachs talking about
biden's plan to prepare
ceos entrepreneurs business owners on
what is going to happen when this takes
place
polls are trending this is the email
those are trending in the democratic
party's favor and while polls are
unreliable they have fueled questions
around what happens to the financial
market
if the democrats take the white house
and or the senate politics aside we are
having conversations with clients around
what if any steps we should take over
the next few months
a few topics of note are below let's go
through these topics with them okay
together number one biden team has
published their tax plan and it outlines
increased corporate tax rates
personal income rates increase and
capital gains tax rates increasing
specifically the plan
outlines an increase in long-term
capital gains which is what anything
above
one year so you buy some i'd buy a card
for 500 000
i sell it two years later for a million
dollars the capital for two million
dollars the capital gains taxes on that
is what a million and a half 500 000
sell it for 2 million i'm paying capital
gains on that additional million and a
half yeah
cost basis tax free one point five bucks
yes exactly by the way that that is why
it said in the article if you look at
the article we read a minute ago
that is why it says getting ready for
the 178 billion dollars of selling ahead
of the capital gains tax hike
why because if you sell now you pay
23.9 on a million bucks let's say
which is 239 000 you get to keep
the additional 700 and whatever 61
thousand dollars
but if you sell effective january 1st
and let's just say they make this 2022
you would have to pay 439 000
instead of 239 that's 2xing which you
would have to pay and on your million
dollars you would only net
560 some thousand dollars that's why
here
it's important that people are selling
off now
not waiting till 2022 so let's continue
so the long-term capital gains taxes
from the current 20 percent
is going to 39.6 so he's not taking 87
25 they said 20 not 35 to 39.6 nobody
should be surprised taxes
is what we're talking about nearly 2x
increase right that's number one second
is he talks about the current gift of
tax exclusion that stands at 11.4
million per person roughly 20 million
per couple
and you know they're thinking about that
this is gonna go lower during obama
administration per person that was five
million dollars
it's supposed to expire by 2025 but he's
saying bite is probably going to speed
up that process and it's going to bring
it down to five million sooner okay so
this may not apply and they're thinking
about making it even more they're
running this applies to you then you go
a little bit deeper here into the tax
plan and here's what you notice
uh biden would raise corporate tax rate
from 21 to 20 percent corporate tax rate
seven initial percent for corporate tax
rate restore the top individual tax rate
from 37 to 39.6 it went lower it's gonna
go back to 39.6
uh tax plan with his tax fund would
raise between three point three five
trillion dollars to three point six
seven trillion dollars over a decade
same thing you've been talking in full
starting in 2021 okay let's say that one
more time that means 3.35 trillion
dollars
of american people is gonna go to the
government that's really what that means
just so you know three point three five
trillion dollars over a decade it's a
lot of money
biden's tax plan is highly progressive
increasing taxes for the top one percent
owners by 13 to 18
okay and then continuously for people
are at the bottom like well i'm not
really
affected by this this is just for the
rich people major proposals by biden's
campaign would raise 1.6 to 1.9 trillion
dollars over a decade from corporations
a trillion trillion will come from high
earners on their income tax 800 billion
two trillion dollars on social security
taxes on highway journals
and then he's adding tax fees uh fees on
bank fees a hundred billion dollars and
a bunch of other things that he's doing
meaning taxes are going up when i told
you the capital gains was going from 20
to 39.6 adam what was your reaction to
it
you know that's pretty it's pretty
unbelievable like i said before the only
uh reason that i personally would vote
for trump
is for the economy taxes this is no
reason to tax only
money guy that's i don't find him
likable i don't find him incredible
okay let me stop right there if you want
to watch the rest of it we'll put the
link here for you to watch the video
on this episode but let's go let's go
back
to this entire conversation about what's
going to happen with this remember
earlier i said to you
there are three different types of
people right those who know they're
aware
that they're directly going to be
impacted by the tax plan right corporate
tax where it's going for 21.28
somebody's got business they want to
sell or something they want to sell you
know
20 to 39 which is really going from
23.9 to 43
they're aware of it then there's a
community of people
who work for somebody who is running
businesses
and is relying on them to make more with
the money that they have the capital
gains
they know they're indirectly going to be
affected by and then there's those who
are not aware that they're indirectly
going to be affected by it
let's forget about the first camp you
know how they're going to be affected by
they already know
they're they're getting ready to get you
know the the increase in taxes what
they'll have to do businesses sell off
stocks
all of that takes place let's talk about
the other two that are indirectly going
to be affected by this now how do you
indirectly get affected by this i
remember
four or five years ago when the taxes
dropped
okay when they dropped i had a meeting
with my staff and i said yank did you
guys hear about what happened with taxes
you know yeah we heard it's going to go
to
20 yes capital gains did you hear about
what's going on with corporate taxes
yeah we hear it's going to go to
21 yes i said do you know what we're
doing what are we doing and i sat there
and i had a conversation with my staff i
said look for every month you've been
with us
we're going to give you a hundred
dollars up to a certain amount of months
and they said wait a minute what do you
mean by that
i said you're getting a hundred dollar
bonus up to a certain amount of months
we're getting 100 bonus for the amount
of months you've been with us and
they're sitting there saying are you
serious and we started giving the
bonuses out and this is not like five
employees
you're paying this to a lot of people
and those bonuses were paid out
everybody said why are we doing this
i said because when the company gets
benefit in taxes
those benefits gets passed down to
everybody else because of the tax cuts
we nearly tripled the amount of
employees that we had because we went
started hiring
and we didn't just hire paying lower
wages i had a meeting
with my staff and i said i want to pay
higher wages
why because the money is flowing through
us i can go higher
pay better wages so rather than saying
hey let's just kind of try to do this
get somebody with a four-year degree get
somebody with an mba on this get
somebody that's got more experience on
this
get somebody with five years experience
get somebody with 10 years experience
rather than let's just get what we can
in this area so it means
the company me us small business owners
were more aggressive being willing to
pay more for talent
to come and work with them work for them
right that's the benefit
so when capital gains goes away
some of these folks that are running
companies they're going to sit there and
say well where's this money going to
come from
maybe we're going to have to cut some
staff maybe we're going to have to cut
some
investment into the company so maybe the
government's going to invest money into
infrastructure
but we got to hold back a little bit and
wait three to four years and see what
we're going to be doing with our
finances right
and then you you'll kind of see those
effects taking place where
well it's the company's fault so there's
going to be a little bit of a division
between employees
working with employers because they're
going to say they're right all you care
about is the money and the employer is
like listen i typically have a little
bit more money that i can deal with with
taxes to put into the business
but at this point of the game we have to
make the decisions ourselves because we
just lost
seven percent on our corporate tax rate
we just doubled our capital gains and
if i'm affected by customers are
affected by it employees are affected by
it i'm affected by everybody is affected
by it
so we have to find somehow to cut
expenses we have to find somehow
to cut the spending that we have
wherever it is there's going to be an
indirect
effect taking place there now let's talk
about the opposite side which is the
real
question to be thinking about there's
two philosophies right there's two
philosophies
i talked about this briefly on what
happened with mayor garcetti
the philosophy is punishment the
philosophy is incentive
i do believe the punishment whatever way
you create with taxes
you're punishing and you're
incentivizing people right
if you lower taxes and you lower the
taxes for small business owners you
produce
more small business owners because the
incentive is let me go take my life
savings
and start a business because the
incentive you're giving me
is you're lowering my capital gains
you're lowering my what my
uh uh corporate taxes so i'm willing to
put more money
into the business and take the risk i'm
willing to take that money out and go
start a business
incentive if you punish and you double
capital gains
you increase corporate tax you increase
everything
up and you're punishing there are side
effects to this
the side effects to this is the
following watch what happens
so think about the states that
businesses are in today that don't pay
state taxes think about those states
okay
let's go to those states first which is
what texas
tennessee you know nevada you know
florida whatever those seven states are
that you're not paying any
state taxes in right so imagine you own
a small business there and they're
sitting there saying
well you know the biden tax plan what is
it going to do
you know i have to pay capital gains
doubling for me i'm going from 20 to
39.6 plus to obamacare
3.9643 that i'm paying for capital gains
corporate tax rates going from 21 to 28.
even with the states that don't have
state taxes they're affected by this
but the problem is not those states let
me tell you what the problem is
the problem is with the states that are
already paying
and charging a lot for taxes so for
those of you
that love states and you live in oregon
you live in new york you live in
california if
you thought due to covid
people left your state the people who
are taking
and making money in capital gains and
running businesses
to make up that 20 increase in capital
gains
they will go and avoid that 13.9 percent
in california and they'll go right next
door to nevada
and yes they'll lose still seven percent
or six percent
but they'll leave california they will
leave new york
and come to florida and miami will boom
south florida will boom
because they're avoiding that additional
taxes that they have to pay in new york
illinois will take a hit you got oregon
will take a hit
so there will be a even more
mass exodus a lot of people left new
york in california
because of how covid was handled meaning
you shut down shutdown shutdown
restaurants restaurants restaurants
nobody left new york in california
because of taxes let's let's understand
that part
people left new york in california
simply because the over
regulations but watch what happens
2020 lots of people leave new york and
california
due to over regulation in 2021 people
are not leaving california and new york
for over regulation because the market's
going to be opening up 2022.
they're going to be leaving new york and
california because of over
taxes so what are florida and texas and
tennessee and these people going to be
doing a lot of people going to be doing
they're going to be upset but they're
going to have to adjust they're going to
have to pivot
they're not going to be happy about it
but they're going to have to make
long-term adjustments and go figure out
a way
a strategy to sit there and whatever
their strategy is gonna be
but this hurts the states that i talked
about
even more and it's back to
back to back now can these taxes pass
senate with 50 seats
i don't know house is proposing can they
pass it their shore
will it make it past joe manchin
probably not if you follow joe manchin's
story joe is not somebody that's going
to be just sitting there saying i'm a
democrat no matter what
he even said there's about six or seven
people that are probably not going to
agree with this
and that are not going to vote for this
on the democratic side on the senate
side
but it's going to be interesting to be
taken to see how this thing ends up
turning out
i think it's a story you ought to be
following because it's going to directly
or
indirectly affect you and your family
and if you are living in one of those
states
where you were worried and concerned and
not happy about the way kobet
was handled and the politicians handled
regulations like imagine how many
restaurant owners
took a hit all these restaurant owners
that took it that are dealing with
margins like this
restaurant owners deal with four five
six seven percent margins
you want to increase their corporate tax
rate from 21 to 28.
they're already dealing with small
margins like i don't they're dealing
with such small margins you
go to a restaurant sit there like
actually sit there and say okay i paid
12 bucks for this hamburger
okay no problem how long did the
waitress serve my table
okay when i came and said on the left
how long was she there
said she helped you you were there for
one hour how many tables was she helping
three other tables that one burger is
ten bucks say the other guys also
ordering burgers for ten bucks
okay what's the cost for the meat what's
the cost for the
bread what's the cost for the paper
plate what's the cost for everything
they brought you
what's her cost what's the cost of the
building
what's the cost of electricity what's
the cost of water
what's the cost of cleaning crew what's
the cost of do you understand like
so then you wanna all these restaurants
you shut down you even wanna put it
like you're putting salt on a wound i
don't know it's it's not a um
i don't know if i would be taking this
direction maybe they're overly confident
about midterms because they don't think
anyone on the right is going to win the
midterms with house and maybe they're
right we don't know yet
but they're playing their cards and
pushing this agenda as if they're
determined that everything's going to be
on their side
but for those of you who voted for this
and you said this will never happen
joe biden if there's anything to give
him and his camp credit of
what they're proposing today it's not
like it was just leaked
yesterday this was released to goldman
morgan
merrill everybody seven eight months ago
and we all knew about it before we voted
so we're just getting
exactly what the majority of americans
voted for
now you got to either hope your senator
votes a different direction
but more importantly you got to have a
strategy to know
whether you're directly or indirectly
affected by this how to make
your own next moves by the way if you
want to see the video you saw on the
podcast where adam and i are talking you
want to kind of hear what we say the
rest of the time click over here to
watch that video
and if you want to watch a video i did
10 reasons to consider moving to another
state
and you're actually getting more serious
about wanting to make another move to
another state
click over here to watch that video with
that being said have a great day
everybody take care bye